Hey, what’s up?
I am Ryan Oksenberg.
I’m a writer/director.
Right off the top I wanted to thank Film Courage
for giving me the opportunity to share with
you some directing lessons that I learned
making DAMAGE CONTROL.
DAMAGE CONTROL is about a man who surprises
his fiancé with a new property and he’s
forced to confront his past behavior.
It’s a classic morality play about karma
coming around in the vein of The Twilight
Zone.
I’ve been making movies since I was a kid.
I used to have one of those Indiglo stopwatches
and I would get all of my toys together and
create these epics and then I would look at
the watch, I’d hit stop and three hours
would have passed.
I would then go to a notepad and write down
what those stories were.
I’ve always been engaged in making movies.
I’ve made short films.
I’ve made documentaries.
I’ve shot things for non-profits (more of
like the corporate thing), the bread-and-butter
thing.
But I’ve also always been writing.
I’ve optioned scripts.
I’ve been hired to adapt novels, I write
with people, I write for people.
Directing is the most fun.
That makes me feel the most alive.
I love being on my feet.
I love problem-solving in the moment and to
do that you’d think, I’m going to prepare.
That night before your shoot, you prepare
like crazy.
I just break down the shots, make my shot
list, I imagine myself in the location, I
write down little things I’m going to whisper
in the actor’s ears.
I’m a hundred and 10 percent prepared.
But on DAMAGE CONTROL what I didn’t prepare
for was being unprepared.
Now I wanted to ask you…have you ever been
in a situation, onset, where this unforeseeable
thing happens and now everything is in disarray
and you’re panicking because you may not
have your movie, you may not make your day.
The biggest lesson that I’ve learned and
that I would say I am still learning is how
to be what I call a malleable director.
A director that could roll with all the punches.
You have to take what the film Gods throw
at you.
It forces you any sort of restriction to be
creative and who knows what could come out
of it?
Maybe there’s a gift on the other end of
that?
The first thing that I learned on DAMAGE CONTROL
about being a malleable director is letting
go of the script.
I had to show the whole history of a relationship
up until this moment in eight minutes.
On set I realized that we didn’t have in
the writing what this relationship was because
we scrambled over in the writing not to have
any expository information about them, that’s
not interesting.
What’s interesting is letting actors be
in the moment in play and convey to us what
the dialogue didn’t about who they are.
Elia Kazan said that the directing is in the
casting and if you cast great people, that’s
who your character is.
The next lesson on being a malleable director
is sale with the wind, not against it.
We had 10 hours to shoot 10 pages over two
days and it was all in available light.
So myself, the cinematographer Andy Chinn,
grip and electric Joseph Tan, we strategically
planned the order that we’re going to shoot
things because DAMAGE CONTROL takes place
in a single moment.
It’s Alison’s lunch break when Drew surprises
her with this new property.
The second day we shot out all the shack stuff.
We reserved the entire morning for it and
we were early.
It went over brilliantly but now we had an
hour and a half until lunch.
So I was like to Andy “Let’s shoot this
now.
Oh now it doesn’t match before, let’s
shoot this.
The light’s not right, we’ve got to shoot
it later.”
And we were waisting time looking at the monitor
and seeing the shots that we shot yesterday
if they matched how the light looked now and
that would determine which shot we would set
up next and then I started worrying “Oh,
we have to move all of our gear this way and
then that way.”
I didn’t know what to shoot?
We spent a half hour talking about what we
could have done and what I neglected to do
was like “Okay, let’s shoot the inserts.”
So you have to learn just how to just throw
away your schedule and be a good editor.
In your head you need to take tally of all
the things that you had shot up until then
and be able to piece it all together in your
head because now you are shooting it piecemeal.
It’s just as important as a director is
now if you’re shooting things out of the
order the actors anticipated, perhaps they
didn’t do the preparation for that scene
or they didn’t lead themselves up emotionally
to it, it’s up to you to be the compass
and guide them back to where they need to
be.
Another phase in production where I learned
to be a more malleable director is in editing.
In my rough cut I was just using medium closes
of Ana in the shack.
I didn’t use any of the wides and I was
pretty committed to it.
I loved the vulnerability that she could express
on her face without saying anything.
I just had an idea of what she had been through
and what she is trying to communicate to Drew
in the shack.
And what I did was I was cutting just to close-ups
of her and then what I was getting was a lack
of mystery and this came from the writer’s
note [Matthew Wygodny].
He was like “Keep Ana back.”
And I did and then it was like I’m going
to build up to that close-up shot, I’m going
to find the best moment to do it and I did
and it worked way better.
You have to serve the story in the edit rather
than the shots you love or the movie that
you had in your head before or else you are
going to not work with the natural rhythms
of what this movie is and you are also going
to be pretty down on yourself because you
have this expectation of what it’s supposed
to be.
But it’s really this so you have to make
this work.
I used to be pretty rigid making my movies.
I used to be pretty insular.
I used to not share my rough cuts with friends.
I used to be afraid to ask crew members “What
does this mean?”
Or “What does this do?”
And on DAMAGE CONTROL was the time where I
just completely let go and I’d like to hear
stories from you guys about gifts (great things)
that came out of problems and how you solve
them and how your movie and yourself as a
director benefited from them.
I hope you guys found this video helpful.
Talking about it is even helpful to me and
working out just how I approach directing
and manage my expectations but when all of
those elements come together, when the performance
is spot-on, the camera movement is spot-on,
the sound is great, just everything is working
operatically and you’re the conductor of
it all, there is no other feeling like it.